what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a girl having a blind
first date and apparently she thinks the
guy is too nice I am going to watch the
video now so make sure you like the
video subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell
[Music]
where's lovely from he's so fun but I
just don't know you know when it's like
it just
it just don't know if he's my Waffle you
know my Waffle how's the day going yes
great she's gorgeous exactly what I've
asked for and she's coming so I don't
want to say about doing much more but
yes great but you understood guys enjoy
your meal thank you
so now I need your story so I've been
single now 18 months yeah
when she moved out I literally went I'm
just gonna go and find myself in did you
go like traveling or anything so yeah I
went to New York I went okay I'm gonna
tell you guys something and this isn't a
fun fact about women but this is just
true don't tell a girl you got dumped
don't do it I think he said she moved
out she left
Alphas don't get dumped they're dumpers
like literally I would just save that
for later it's kind of like there's some
things you don't tell people right away
if you got dumped I would just save it
because girls are gonna automatically
think like why did he get dumped like
what's wrong with you the same way you
might say that about a woman I don't
think men are as picky about that but
women we are it's not a fun fact it's
just the top of the Empire State
Building
New York's the most romantic place in
the world
he was really really nice
possibly too nice what is it you're
looking for do you know what I don't
even know anymore
[Music]
red flag I want to Street in I want to
be Street no oh God
so one of my things is like I've got
really girdy hands okay let's have a
look
she is definitely girl for material she
looks gorgeous in her red dress I would
love to go on another date for Katie
to have really small hands I do have
really small hands
it's like guys have such low bars I mean
she does
bonjour hello
are you feeling
so nervous
no no no no no no please no no no no no
there's so many nerves going on right
now no no no no no
you like to see each other again
oh they make them do it in front of each
other oh that's so awkward I as a
gentleman I'll go first okay
I would like to see her again
okay now it feels super bad oh no so so
so so so so so so so so so so so so
sorry
like I really enjoyed your company I
thought I don't know if I can spend the
best yeah I just think he's he's kind of
awkward I think that's the problem she'd
been Alpha widowed it just is what it is
you're not as good as her ex yeah that
sounds bad she likes the it's
okay oh thank you so much I kind of do
like you but I don't know if I like you
but I say actually do you know what I
don't really wind
total rewind
you know what why not why not give it
another girl
no don't accept that
are you gonna go all right blessing Kobe
you're gonna go for a girl you wanna go
out again
um well no well you know what why not
why not I mean
yeah he said he said that means she's
gonna friend zone you it's like what
you're gonna get friend zoned on date
too this is what rela tomasi talks about
this how like a girl that's actually
into you isn't going to make you wait
that long like she's not really into him
thank you very much you're funny
you're interesting you're good looking
if you want to take me to see your
package I'll take you to see the alpacas
I'll come and see your old Packers what
a true gentleman no I can't put the
money down I just hit my head
Haram Haram
I want I have so much empathy for the
men you know what I mean like you guys
put up with such from women
like and sometimes it's your own damn
fault it's your own and I'm not I'm
sorry I'm sorry but this Haram Haram
don't accept that you should want a girl
that's actually into you not just ah
well maybe why do you guys do this to me
why do you do this to me okay well like
the video on your way out subscribe this
isn't as bad as the one the pregnant one
you should check out that video too
um but horrible still like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible